ننوه بالاخبار العاجله وكاله الانباء
السوريه تقول ان هجوما استهدف مبدا سكنيا
في حي المزه بدمشق وهو ناجم عن عدوان
اسرائيلي اذا هجوم يستهدف مبنى سكني في حي
المزه بدمشق وهو ناجم كما تقول وكاله
الانباء
السوريه على الاغلب عن
عدوان اسرائيلي وهذه صور اوليه لهذا
الاستهداف وهذا القصف الذي تقول وكاله
الانباء السوريه انه على الاغلب ناجم عن
عدوان
اسرائيلي اذا من جديد نشاهد هذه الصور
الاوليه التي وردت وتتعلق بهذا الهجوم
الذي يستهدف مبنى سكني كما نلاحظ من خلال
هذه الصور في حي المزه هذا الحي في
العاصمه السوريه دمشق تقول وكاله الانباء
السوريه انه ناجم على الاغلب عن عدوان
اسرائيلي وسنتوقف طبعا ل المزيد من
المعلومات اذا ما توافرت مع مدير مكتب
الجزيره بعد قليل وليد العمري ربما لديه
المزيد من المعلومات
والايضاحات فيما يتعلق بهذا الاستهداف
بالاضافه الى مراسل الجزيره في سوريا الا
اننا نعيد ونذكر
بما جاء في هذا الخبر العاجل نقلا عن
وكاله الانباء السوريه التي تؤكد وقوع هذا
الهجوم وتقول هجوم يستهدف مبنى سكنيا في
حي المزه بدمشق وان هذا الهجوم كما تقول
وكاله الانباء السوريه ناجم على الاغلب عن
عدوان اسرائيلي